selenium so selenium is an element
that's quite like sulfur but sulfur has
its common form in s8 rings whereas
selenium exists in its more common form
as long chains of selenium atoms and if
you shine light on these chains they
start conducting electricity
so selenium was the material that was
used in some of the early photocells for
things like burglar alarms and doors
that open themselves and so on so here's
a sample of selenium and we're going to
unpack it from the box here and it's in
the form of a shot selenium has a number
of other applications perhaps the one
that amuses me most is that it's used in
shampoos some people as you know get
dandruff which is called by it caused by
bacteria on their scalp and if you use a
compound which is a ring which is a
mixture of sulfur and selenium this can
be added to shampoo and will act as a
bacterial side and will kill the
bacteria that cause dandruff so let's
see what comes out you can hear it here
you can see the selenium wonderful black
compound beautiful element again this is
a mineral which is useful for us and in
fact many people often take selenium as
an additive to their diet however you
have to be careful because the compounds
that make our sweat smell are sulfur
compounds so if you get selenium into
the body then you make the similar
compounds of selenium but which smell
much worse and so it is said that people
get off the bus when selenium chemists
get on and tellurium is even worse still